I did not come to a pleasure to lose you
just rub poo all over me
[Music]
previously Amazon's the grantor
challenged us to a dune buggy race and a
fan boat race weird Alaska
only two points separate first place
from last place so it's really anyone's
game still the Grand Tour guys are here
again to tell us what dumb thing I have
to learn and lose that we skied cars in
Colorado cars seems very unsafe you guys
you can't do that but we do want to see
you race each other
in the snow if racing in the snow means
you'll crash you still upset about the
Revolutionary War it's the grand finale
of the try guys dirty tour talks led
facing last time we got sweaty in the
swamp today we're doing it doggy style
I've been planning that since 5:00 a.m.
dog sledding or mushing is the Alaska
State sport and it's a very primitive
form of transportation are you related
we raced and raised and trained sled
dogs here in Alaska it's very
instinctual for them to want to run and
pull they love it they're addicted to it
and it's our job to harness that
addiction we have about 50 dogs will
travel anywhere from 50 to a thousand
mile races sounds cold
yeah the coldest we've raced in a 63
below negative 63 that's not a real
number so today we're gonna do some
dryland training get you guys familiar
with the dogs help us with some chores
and race so why do we do first I think
we should meet the dogs okay there's so
many if our dogs are called Alaskan
Huskies and they look like pound puppies
versus the Siberian Husky which we also
called a slow Berrian iceberg I'm often
told that I don't have a soul but if you
know me the one glimmer of hope I have
is animals do you big spooning the dog
it's booting the dog who's on my butt
excuse me it's a lifestyle being able to
raise and train dogs and see them grow
and mature you take puppies that you've
held when they're just fresh born and
then doing their first race is choke see
hopefully I know this but a Doberman
jumped in my stroller when I was three I
was scarred for life most of my life
I've tried to be not afraid of dogs okay
hello yes hello I'm a cat person I like
cats dogs are completely non discerning
with their love you want a cat one day
next day they hate you I like that so
here's one of our dog sleds these are
your runners and your foot pad so you
stand right here do you want to slow
down some you stand on this brake if you
want to stop me stand on this brake
today when we're practicing we're not
gonna be using the sled so we'll use the
ATV four-wheelers they'll be pulling the
four wheels in neutral you'll get a good
experience of what it all looks like how
it feels handling the dogs
imagine doing this all by yourself in
negative 40 degrees
oh my god ready already
oh well it'll more serious like you're
ready when you're calling your leaders
places this all voice commands so if you
want to turn right obg and if you I'll
go left you'll say ha so here's your
first left-hand turn go ahead first race
I didn't go fast enough beggar raise I
went too fast so this race
full throttle forward it's gonna be like
fairly accurate throttle over will
workshop it later part of your training
will be learning how to harness the dogs
and get them ready to run you can't do
it with gloves on the only thing you can
do with gloves on his pee your pants
like USP as a sled still going yep got a
good dog musher never steps in dog poop
so are you saying about me easy Oh am I
sitting on the poo yeah you stepped in
again I don't know what my strategy is
my strategy was to grow a beard and
learn the skills that has not worked I'm
the cutest boys like you
average I'd like to keep it right around
10 miles an hour they like consistency
this is almost like a treadmill workout
for them one of our mandatory items a
carry on the sled is an axe the case
there's a tree down on the trail last
time I did this I was a 13 year old yeah
and they taught me this very safe way of
doing it where you just go like and then
you lift the entire thing up and just go
keep keeps talking about how I'm a witch
or a wizard or a nice mage really I
think I'm just the most in touch with my
surroundings I do talk to dogs though so
if any video involves me having magic it
might be this one stop stop stop stop
they were not going where you wanted to
stop them and then keep saying the
command
just like that way to taxi let's saw
that [ __ ]
when you stop everything is about taking
care of your dog team you're the last
one that gets rest and food and
everything like that so there's a sleep
deprivation sport
thoughts always come first with
everything we do it's all Excel for the
highest standard these dogs are kings
yeah I don't have to bow down to them
you know bow-wow I won last time I feel
good no one's mentioned that dogsledding
is funny it's a bunch of dogs pretending
they're reindeer thinking I'm Santa
that's hilarious the stretch gggggg
great great great great stop stop stop
stop stop the main line that the dogs
are on it's called the gang line you
can't have that accordion up in a ball
because you're gonna get in the big tank
getting in a tangle will lose you they
will lose the race all right quit it's
very little that we can possibly learn
to make this work that is it entirely
hinging on the training that the dogs
have the dogs have arrived it's time for
the preliminary race
it sounds like they're driving
Oh what's happening with net and I
finally practice without any of the
twins everything went wrong those heroes
I missed the first turn in our practice
and then I was just on a wild goose
chase my dogs were taking me everywhere
[Music]
I was freaking out it was a nightmare
easy whoa for a minute there I was like
this is how I died you did a good job on
trusting your dogs ready all right ready
all right nice and easy boys let's not
have another net and keep situation yeah
everybody sucks these dogs are out of
control
okay hey how's it going on the racetrack
well we came to find you wrestler here
so this autonomous actually did the race
here he comes
good job Eugene G G oh I had the pick a
winner I think it was you team
why didn't you gene do well that we can
all copy in the main race you guys did
awesome we can't wait to see what to do
up on the glacier boy it's race day this
morning we got onto a sea plane and flew
miles and miles into the middle of
nowhere and land it on a lake
it's over a hundred miles to the nearest
road which means it's over a hundred
miles to the nearest hospital very
scared you're getting on a helicopter
and landing on a [ __ ] glacier
come on beard give me something I've
never had a win
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
after yesterday I feel really confident
now time to throw out the window because
we're not driving ATVs today we're
driving actual dog sleds and we have not
practiced that at all Oh God
I'm in first place right now I'm the top
dog I intend to keep it that way
going lightheaded getting on ahead I'm
gonna prove that I can win this dogs in
a competition on talent alone no magic
involved come on spirit of Alaska in the
glacier we got this gee I don't think
I've ever been more physically nervous
and really scared to do something how
long is this
it's about a mile you do a thousand of
these okay focus hike
ready go deep on Rosi flat sir I'm told
that the two videos being called Andy
Andy and fan person I did not come to a
[ __ ] pleasure to lose this is
terrifying I could not be doing this
this is what athletes do I'm not an
athlete I'm Keith okay okay any troubles
Danny talk hi guys lunch will spill over
you're doing amazing sweetie this is
crazy
what ever happened to us just turn it on
ladies underwear
I felt that the dogs were slowing down
and every time I did I just took the
twins advice to try to pedal and then I
just ran
how does he still look like a model aw
he's doing I know doesn't he look so
sexy like he should be in a ski magazine
I felt like I was the seventh dog I
really was able to tap into that primal
power mush Christie Nana kept talking
about that during races real mushers
they pee while they're going I don't
know what that's like
I can't get my dick out oh no no come
back puppy
wait he's riding behind this way I'm
sorry that I said cats are better the
dogs go back come back doggies oh oh
that was stupid
[Music]
over the entire series I've struggled
with finding that right speed and today
I was fully in control Fulmer I control
the dogs we're a team and I'm the coach
[Music]
as it's sort of mellowed out and the
dogs got their initial energy spent it's
just so beautiful I didn't really think
about trying to win as much as I thought
about trying to do this right now just
[ __ ] go for it boys go honey
be one with you much my babies hey all
right don't stop go puppies go prove to
them that can't be boy dog move oh yeah
yeah does he seven girls don't you see
hub they decided that we were done my
beautiful babies I was one with all of
you Eugene just be careful because
there's a giant puddle of pee so right
I'm one with the dogs now it's time for
the final results first place with a
time of 8 minutes in three seconds way
we all won won first place in you
geniuses change any loser again but
Keith did not go through the finish line
at first so therefore he had a time of 8
minutes 13 seconds in Eugene one
tell me in a crevasse still not a wizard
it was all skill baby learning how to
dogsled it has been one of the greatest
experiences of my life I'm no longer
gonna say that I'm a little afraid of
dogs
I'm gonna say I used to be afraid of
dogs when dogs really made me work for
it I'm not gonna say I'm a dog person
but maybe I'm a little more okay with
them than I was when I came in here we
were on the helicopter up and I almost
started cheering up at how lucky we
really are to be able to go and do some
of these things in the past three videos
I've been able to see how beautiful and
how varied this world is I flew in a
helicopter today and the dog said I
think earlier I said nobody should try
this go back on that I think everybody
should try everything thank you all so
much for watching the dirty tour until
next time
what will we try next I'm gonna try worn
bad no no I'm saying
try snow angels think we I think we have
to oh oh it's so hot on this glacier but
these blue squares have been itching to
get see this is a mistake it's too cold
for this okay I'm not doing this do we
want to keep stripping